des prix du pétrole négatif l'incroyable
s'est donc produit cette semaine avec la
chute à - 37 dollar du baril de brut
américain un plongeon historique l'excès
d'offre sur le marché telles que
certains sont prêts à payer pour qu'on
les débarrassent de leur production
alors comment en est on arrivé là
peut-on l'expliquer par la seule crise
du corona virus le secteur pétrolier
peut-il sont relevées on voit tout cela
avec vous l'économiste jacques sapir
bonsoir ac bienvenue toujours avec nous
via skype évidemment jacques que se
passe-t-il sur le marché du pétrole
alors stéphanie comme vous l'avez dit
l'économie l'épidémie ducobu de 19 et
surtout le confinement des principales
économies a eu un impact direct sur le
marché du pétrole avec une chute très
brutale de la demande mais ce n'est pas
la seule explication au jour
extraordinaire que nous venons de vivre
parce que au-delà de ce que j'appelle le
corona craque c'est à dire ce krach
pétroliers sur fond de coronavirus et
bien nous avons trois pays qui sont en
train de s'affronter sur le marché du
pétrole il ya l'arabie saoudite la
russie et les etats unis
et cet affrontement a eu un rôle
déterminant dans ce qui vient de se
passer
alors jacques a tout d'abord une
question simple comment un bien matériel
comme le pétrole peut-il avoir un prix
négatif
il faut donc expliquer car on a parfois
du mal à y croire vous avez tout à fait
raison c'est fini tout d'abord il faut
rappeler que quand on parle du prix du
pétrole
c'est en réalité une simplification il y
à des prix du pétrole alors
essentiellement il y en a deux banques
fait y en a plus mais disons-le y en a
deux qui sont principaux qui servent à
10 peu de prix directeur le brent pour
le marché du pétrole qui est à londres
et le west texas intermédiaire ipt le
doublé outil high commun dit dont le
marché et aux états unis
l'épisode des prix négatifs s'est
produit sur le double outillage et pas
sur le brent alors en plus il faut
savoir que les marchés du pétrole
sont ce que l'on appelle des marchés au
futur on achète par exemple une quantité
de pétrole en mars ou en avril pour être
livrés physiquement au début du mois de
mai alors jacques qu'est ce que cela
veut dire de l'état de la demande aux
états unis par exemple
alors ce qui s'est passé et c'est fini
c'est qu'avec la baisse de la demande
les acheteurs ont cherché des réservoirs
pour stocker le pétrole qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas utiliser dans l'immédiat
or pratiquement toutes les capacités de
stockage sont aujourd'hui soit utilisés
soit loué et en particulier à
l'extrémité de l'oléoduc de look là où
là où se font justement les transactions
sur le double routière alors les gérer
les acheteurs ont cherché désespérément
à se débarrasser des quantités de
pétrole qui ne pouvaient plus stockées
et c'est cela qui a provoqué justement
cet effondrement des prix et que le
marché est ce qu'on appelle un marché
aux futurs les acheteurs ont cherché à
revendre les quantités qu'ils avaient
acquise provoquant ainsi des ventes à
perte comme on dit dans le jargon
ils ont vendu short et ce sont ses
ventes à pertes qui ont entraîné le prix
au dessous de zéro alors il faut
comprendre que cet épisode est largement
le fait tout d'abord d'une pénurie de
moyens de stockage mais aussi d'un
affolement spéculatifs sur un marché aux
futurs alors jacques on comprend mieux
effectivement comment on a pu arriver à
des prix négatifs mais ce que c'est
aussi le signe que la demande s'est
effondrée
et oui évidemment cet effet nick et si
l'on comparé à la les courbes des prix
on voit bien que ces dernières qui était
au dessus de 60 dollars le baril
commence à baisser à partir de la
deuxième quinzaine de janvier quand la
chine se décide à confiner sa population
mais ce que l'on voit aussi sur les
courbes c'est que à partie
du 6 mars la baisse commence à
s'accélérer et c'est ceci qui nous
indique que l'épidémie ducobu 19 n'est
pas la seule responsable de cette baisse
des prix
et que s'est-il passé jacques le 6 mars
alors le 6 mars nous avions à vienne en
autriche
une réunion des pays de l'opep à
laquelle était invité la russie
c'est ce que l'on appelle d'ailleurs le
format opep plus pays de l'opep plus la
route
cette réunion avait pour but de discuter
de nouvelles baisses de production pour
tenter justement de faire remonter les
cours
quand le ministre du pétrole russe
monsieur novak est arrivé à vienne
il a déclaré qu'il était impensable que
de nouvelles mesures soient décidées
tant que les états unis qui sont devenus
et ça c'est un changement important
depuis une dizaine d'années qui sont
devenu un exportateur de poids avec leur
pétrole de schiste ne prendrai pas leur
part justement dans ces baisses de
production l'arabie saoudite a alors
dénoncé les accords existants et décider
de pompey autant de pétrole que possible
afin de gagner des parts de marché et
c'est cela qui a provoqué ce qu'il faut
bien appeler une espèce de guerre des
prix au moment où justement la demande
mondiale se réduisait de près d'un tiers
sur fond de crise du coronavirus et
c'est l'aja qui a provoqué le plongeon
des prix oui c'est fait c'est cela qui a
provoqué le plongeon des prix le prix
calculé sur l' indice américain sur le
wti est passé rapidement sous la barre
des 30 dollars
les jours suivants le brun a suivi mais
en décalé et c'est cette baisse des prix
qui a provoqué une véritable crise alors
c'est aussi une crise industrielle aux
etats unis
mais jacques pourquoi précisément aux
états unis eh bien ces familles il faut
regarder le coût d'extraction les coûts
de production du pétrole de schiste aux
états unis
ce conte moyen varie de 23 à 36 dollars
le baril seulement voilà c'est une
moyenne
et pour de nous
breuses petites et moyennes compagnies
le prix se situe plutôt entre 45 et 50
dollars le baril alors prix de l' indice
wta et qui est inférieur à 30 dollars de
très nombreuses petites compagnies qui
sont en général lourdement endetté font
faillite
d'ailleurs dès le début du mois d'avril
près d'un travailleur sur deux de
l'industrie pétrolière américaine a été
licencié avec un prix inférieur à 20 $
ce qui est la situation actuelle même
largement en dessous par moments de ces
20 dollars c'est tout le secteur qui est
sinistré et c'est pourquoi
donald rhin a décidé de lancer un
programme spécial de soutien à
l'industrie du pétrole et du gaz et
qu'il envisage même de terreau dire les
importations de pétrole aux états unis
alors on veut penser à chaque
logiquement que cette chute des prix
fait également malo aux autres
producteurs
oui évidemment stéphanie la russie par
exemple dont le pétrole est rattachée à
lundi ce brain s'ouvre mais elle souffre
moins que les autres ne serait ce que
parce que son budget était calculée sur
un prix assez bas sur un prix de 40
dollars le baril et quelle à d'amples
aux réserves de change et il faut bien
le dire un système fiscal qui est très
protecteur pour les compagnies
pétrolières
néanmoins elle souffre aussi et puis il
faut parler de l'arabie saoudite qui est
certainement le pays qui aujourd'hui est
celui qui souffre financièrement le plus
et c'est pour ça que les pays de l'opep
plus ont décidé finalement de réduction
importante de la production pour environ
10 millions de barils par jour alors est
ce que ce sera suffisant
non c'est fait non il faudra aller plus
loin surtout il faudrait que les etats
unis eux aussi acceptent de s'engager
dans un cadre contraignant alors il faut
dire qu'il s'y prépare d'ailleurs car la
production a baissé d'environ 4 millions
de barils par jour rien qu'aux états
unis
alors jacques selon vous est-ce qu'un
accord est possible
stéphanie un nouvel accord est en
réalité inévitable même si on ne sait
pas encore sous quelle forme se
manifestera quelle forme prendra les
états unis n'ont guère d'autre choix que
de se coordonner avec leurs adversaires
d'hier
il faut bien dire que la de ce point de
vue là la leçon a porté le marché du
pétrole va donc se réorganiser et c'est
réorganisation se fera d'ailleurs en
parallèle avec le déconfinement des
grandes économies
il est clair que ça va prendre du temps
mais cette réorganisation est à terme
inévitable
merci j'ai pensé explications et cette
analyse de la crise des prix du pétrole
et à bientôt sur rt france